ah I'll tell you a little boring little
secret about how I got to be Who I am I
grew up in a town in western Colorado
where if you read Time magazine you were
suspect of being some kind of left-wing
intellectual I mean this was this was
podunk and and as I grew up there I
became aware of all these extremely
strongly expressed cultural values and
most of them were hostile to something
either Jews were bad they're black
people are bad they're people who didn't
work were bad or people who made messy
paintings were bad all of these things
were bad and one day it occurred to me I
will take the position that all these
things are good these things are good
Abstract Expressionism Jews black people
science good good good good and
everybody said there's something wrong
with this kid but and I didn't
understand my own position I mean I
would look at a Pollock and think you
know it is messy
it may be horseshit but we must never
admit that we must defend that and we
must defend the genius of Pollock unto
death because we don't understand him
and by taking that position slowly I
actually did understand some of these
things and make them my own and I
discovered that that was the path to
wisdom a total rejection of my own of
the culture I came up with well now I
don't know how that would work if you
were born of Jewish parents in New York
who were members of the Communist Party
and always took you to wonderful art
exhibitions and made sure you got to
Carnegie if you rejected all that you'd
become
jerk like the people around me in that
small Colorado town so this is not a
fail-safe prescription but in my case by
an embracing of everything artificial
and antithetical and opposed by and
sneered at by the people around me i
night i made my way to you know real
depth real worth real culture things not
that i assimilated these things but at
least i came to live in the light of
them it's a great puzzle i mean in all
of you who have children and i have to
know that we are alienated intellectual
i mean that broadly speaking this is
what we are we are alienated
intellectuals and so we [ __ ] about the
government and we critique the monetary
system and so forth and so on
well then you see your children on the
brink of the reason and you say you know
geez my alienation has brought me
alienation but i can't let the kids grow
up to be marked to be pawns of the
market economy and the propaganda
machine people scratching their heads
trying to figure out whether they're
Republicans or Democrats I can't put
that on my children and so then you say
well okay then they must join in the
alienation they must be taken out of the
culture as we were taken out of the
culture and this is a momentous decision
because you this act of separating from
the culture is unambiguously alienating
and yet it seems to be the only way to
find the self
otherwise you never contact the self you
contact a commodified cartoon of the
self that finds meaning and outboard
motors and basketball
and you know all this other crap that's
peddled as reality so our relationship
to our culture I think is a very
uncomfortable one and of course
psychedelics exacerbate this and you
know I think if you have children that
it's one thing to talk a lien nation but
once they get to the place where they're
asking to take LSD or to take Phyllis
Hyman and you know Kafka said a
wonderful thing I think it's in the
penal colony he said you can choose to
be freed but it's the last choice you'll
ever and that's that's sort of the
dilemma in which we find ourselves
[Music]
you
[Music]